I Il fut un temps où une visite
dudu prince Charles soulevait
leles foules au Canada. Peut-ête
ététait-ce la présence de Diana
ouou était-ce simplement une aue
épépoque. Le fils aîné de la ree
a a entamé une visite de
trtrois jours. Elle s'inscrit ds
lele cadre du jubilé de platine,
7070 ans de règne d'Élisabeth I.
EÉcoutons le prince Charles
auaujourd'hui à Terre-Neuve-et-
LaLabrador.
- - On profite de cette visite
popour se poser la question :
lala monachie a-t-elle encore
sasa place au Canada? Est-il tes
dede s'en affranchir? Voici la
réréponse de Justin Trudeau.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - On a des institutions fortes
auau Canada, on a une démocratie
trtrès forte. Et à un moment où
jujustement on voit la démocrate
sosous attaque littéralement
enen Ukraine, mais aussi des dés
auau niveau de nos institutions
dédémocratiques à travers
lele monde, c'est un moment pour
sasavoir, pour être très content
ququ'on ait un système très sole
auau Canada. Et pour être honnê,
momoi mes plus grandes
prpréoccupations, c'est le coût
dede la vie, les changements
clclimatiques. Des changements
coconstitutionnels, il y a pas
énénormément de gens qui m'en
paparlent régulièrement.
- - J'en discute avec Benoit
PePelletier, professeur de droit
coconstitutionnel à l'Université
d'd'Ottawa. Bonsoir!
- - Bonsoir!
IlIl y a de moins en moins des
CaCanadiens qui favorisent le
mamaintien de la monarchie
coconstitutionnelle. Êtes-vous
susurpris par le peu de soutien
quque reçoit la monarchie?
- - Enfin c'est difficile à
évévaluer parce que ce sera
vrvraiment au moment du décès de
SaSa Majesté Élisabeth II consos
HBHBO Canada se développent au n
unun vaste mouvement en faveur e
l'l'abolition de la monarchie.
TaTant que Élisabeth II est rei,
ététant donné sa popularité, étt
dodonné sa prestance et sa
didignité, il y a moins de gens
ququi sont favorables à
l'l'abolition de la monarchie qe
pepeut-être il y en aura au momt
dede son décès.
- - On voit un tableau pendant
ququ'on se parle. C'est une grae
mamajorité qui réponde non. Il a
ququand même des gens qui
dedemeurent incertain. Le Québec
rereçoit le plus faible appui.
AuAu Canada, ces 26 oui contre .
EÉlisabeth II a écrit l'histoire
dedepuis 70 ans de règne, c'est
bebeaucoup. Elle a rencontré
bebeaucoup de premier ministre,
elelle a signé la constitution e
lele Québec refuse toujours. Es-
cece que ce sera un choix basé r
lala personnalité ou l'opportuné
dede changer de régime politique
seselon vous?
- - Je crois que ce sera fondé r
l'l'occasion qui se présenterai.
JeJe crois que Charles va gagner
enen popularité au cours des
prprochaines années. Donc je ne
pepense pas que ça va être un
chchoix personnel des Canadiens.
SiSi l'Barbade a mis fin à la
momonarchie il y a un an, le
CaCanada pourrait très bien en
fafaire de même éventuellement.
EtEt la question qu'on doit se
poposer si jamais les gens sont
fafavorables à l'abolition, c'et
: : par quel processus, par quel
sysystème plutôt on remplacerait
lala monarchie constitutionnelle
auau Canada.
NoNous avons un parlementarismee
tytype britannique qui s'accomme
trtrès bien d de la présence d'n
sosouverain ou d'une souveraine.
AlAlors il va vraiment falloir
réréfléchir aussi au modèle de
reremplacement.
- - Une première question parce
quque vous savez il n'y a pas
bebeaucoup d'amoureux des débats
coconstitutionnels, ne vous en
dédéplaise. Et les règles
coconstitutionnelles ici seraiet
asassez exigeantes pour arriverà
unun amendement qui permettrait
unune transitio des institution.
CeCe n'est pas demain la veille
quque ça va se produire, en tout
cacas pas avec Justin Trudeau.
- - Non, on peut le penser maisn
mmême temps si la population,
dadans le cadre de référendums,
vovotent en faveur de l'abolitin
dede la monarchie, je verrai trs
mamal les politiciens s'y oppos.
UnUn référendum serait le coup
d'd'envoi à une modification
coconstitutionnelle et une
rérévolution constitutionnelle
mamais de portée limitée. On ne
pepeut pas revenir à Meech né à
ChCharlottetown mais s'il y avat
unune modification de portée
lilimitée mais néanmoins
susubstantielle comme le voudrat
l'l'abolition de la monarchie, à
cece moment-là dans le cadre de
réréférendums allégeant pourrait
dodonner le signal aux politicis
dedes deux langues.
- - Justin Trudeau est le chef e
gogouvernement. La gouverneure
gégénérale qui représente la ree
etet l'chef d'État. L'Barbade
l'l'fait, d'autres veulent
égégalement laisser la monarchi.
EsEst-ce qu'on peut garder un
sysystème parlementaire basé sur
leles principes de responsabilié
miministérielle à l'britanniquet
avavoir un chef d'État? Ou le cf
dede gouvernement et le chef de
l'l'État ça peut être la même
pepersonne?
- - C'est possible mais il
fafaudrait qu'on est à ce momen-
llà un président ou une
prprésidente plutôt qu'un
sosouverain désigné par
l'l'hérédité. On aurait un
prprésident ou une présidente. l
y y a des gens qui imaginent des
foformules intermédiaires. Ils
imimaginent que les fonctions du
gogouverneur général pourraient
êêtre assumées par le juge en
chchef ou l'juge en chef de la
cocour suprême du Canada.
PoPour les provinces ce serait e
jujuge en chef de la cour d'appl
dede la province. Mais ça pose n
prproblème selon moi en vertu du
prprincipe de la séparation des
popouvoirs parce qu'il y a
vrvraiment des moments dans note
hihistoire qui se sont présentée
etet qui peuvent se présenter ds
l'l'avenir ou le rôle du monarqe
n'n'est pas que symbolique. Le
momonarque a vraiment un choix à
fafaire en fonction des règles s
coconventions constitutionnelles
etet de la légitimité politique.
JeJe vois mal un jour j'en chef
asassumait de telles fonctions.
- - Et le juge en chef et bien
d'd'autres choses à faire que de
s's'occuper de ce que fait
nonormalement un chef d'État. Iy
a a beaucoup de protocoles, de
rereprésentation de l'État. Le
jujuge en chef, il a autre chosà
fafaire que cela. Parlons des
rerelations avec les autochtones
paparce que c'était en cause les
trtraités avec la couronne
brbritannique. Le prince est ici
auaussi pour avoir des échanges
avavec des autochtones dans ce
cocontexte sur les pensionnats
auautochtones alors qu'ils fontà
unune, qu'il préoccupe beaucoup
leles communautés. Qu'est-ce qui
ararriverait de se traiter?
- - Les traités resterait en ple
: : il y aurait vraiment une
cocontinuité en ce qui concernea
gogouverne de l'étang. Une
cocontinuité absolument complèt.
IlIl y a un tracteur qui est
inintéressant à noter, c'est que
lele concept d'État en tant que
tetel est un concept qui est
prpresque absent en droit
coconstitutionnel britannique.
CeCe à quoi ils font référence a
plplupart du temps et la courone
enen tant que telle.
LeLe concept d'État est beaucoup
plplus familier à ceux qui ont e
cuculture française disons.
MaMais il n'en reste pas moins e
lala couronne représente l'État,
l'l'État en même temps se
trtranspose dans la couronne. Iy
a a si je puis dire une
ininterconnexion entre ces deux
coconcepts. Et même si la couroe
dedevait disparaître, l'État
rerestera bien entendu.
- - Benoît Pelletier, merci
bebeaucoup. Pendant qu'on vous
paparle, on voit la vision du
prprince et de la duchesse à
OtOttawa. Il devrait quitter
l'l'avion d'un instant à l'autr.
OnOn va quand même se laisser l-
dedessus parce que de toute façn
dedemain, on